par là où dans la bataille où la tempête
fin de malchance en mains le sang durant
la période du ramadan le capitaine
nouredine abdou sène dirige son équipe
de bénévoles dans un gymnase de
pierrefitte sur seine en seine saint
denis cette dernière doit remplir sa
mission du jour préparé plus de 400
repas pour les nécessiteux avec son
association laisser les servir créé en
2006 le capitaine propose des séjours
des missions de solidarité aux jeunes
des quartiers souvent en décrochage
scolaire ancien officier il est inspiré
par l'organisation de l'armée
il souhaite offrir un cadre et inculquer
les valeurs républicaines
l'amour du drapeau à ces adolescents en
manque de repères nous on est une
association qui font de l'accompagnement
des jeunes à travers les codes de la
république de la citoyenneté la
confessionnalité nous accompagnons les
jeunes à ce que valorise leur image
d'une part il s'agit pas de faire ça
pendant deux jours et se reposer c'est
pendant 40 jours et les contraintes
émancipatrice fournir un service auprès
de la population en mettant en place les
règles qu'aux vide
et ça ça marche il ne s'épargne aucun
effort pour faire régner la discipline
et la rigueur tu finis à ça près ce que
je veux c'est que tu me contrôler si ça
marche là-bas l'urgence est la machine
masse les mecs priorité si on leur a
point être carré et à y est rare cheese
et les besoins mais je pense qu'on va
être très efficace au moment des crises
j'ai fait plusieurs camps avec le
capitaine ce qui m'a donné envie de
continuer c'est la rigueur le tout sur
tout ce que les valeurs que le capitaine
nous montre aider les plus démunis c'est
un truc important puisque en fait on se
rend compte que il est très simple de
passer de ce côté là donc on essaie de
contribuer un petit peu améliorer leur
quotidien
j'ai toujours voulu aider les gens
soient aux musulmans pas musulman c'est
pour tout le monde à la fois
personnellement je suis bien après quand
je rentre j'ai dit oh moi j'ai fait
quelque chose aujourd'hui pour aider les
personnes
l'association qui fonctionne grâce aux
dons a reçu la visite de l'équipe
municipale qui la soutient pour préparer
veut pas dans ces conditions sanitaires
assez restrictif c'est très compliqué
maintenant c'est vrai que la ville a mis
à disposition un gymnase qui est quand
même assez spacieux on essaye vraiment
de faire avec les moyens qu'on a
donc on à voile à aménager les locaux de
telle sorte aussi à ce qu' il ait pas
trop de proximité
mission accomplie 472 repas seront
proposés à 14h aux associations qui les
distribueront le soir aux personnes dans
le besoin aux étudiants dans des foyers
14 heures les cagettes pour les
heureusement que ce genre d'association
existe surtout dans cette période et
pandémie il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
sont retrouvés vraiment sans rien
nouredine abdou sène ne craint pas de
discuter avec les caïds de la ville pour
qu'ils se rendent utiles et cherche
également à rétablir le dialogue entre
les forces de police les jeunes et les
mamans nous évoquons sur les murs les
valeurs de la république parce qu'on vit
dans ce pays
avant tout on doit être républicain et
oui c'est pour me dire que je suis fier
du ramadan à ce moment là oui mais si on
ne fait rien au mois du ramadan pour
s'améliorer afin que nos voisins
quels qu'ils soient les entre les autres
onze mois de l'année soit identique à
celui là bas je crois pas le champ de
travail encore immense vous construire
le vivre ensemble et à prendre
l'exemplarité bon capitaine a choisi sa
méthode au chevet des quartiers